[Musique]
pas de vacances cet été pour me wade à l
interprète les mata hari burlesque et
amoureuse amoureuse d'un pierre richard
plus naïfs et d'istres et que jamais
dans le nouveau film de yves robert
le grand blond avec une chaussure noire
des prises de vue en lui au studio de
boulogne
j'ai invité quelques amis pourriez faire
un seul venir boire un verre avec nous
sinon adresse 85 rue des plantes
soupire ce soir
yves robert explique contre un solide la
tipp curieux mais qui s'explique très
simplement et des gravures pour qu'on
ait un titre aussi long et nos deux
titres longs ont pas du tout non nous
francis veber et moi qui avons écrit ce
scénario avons pensé simplement que
c'est une manière de désigner quelqu'un
comme on dit le petit avec un pardessus
sagna aucune astuce derrière il ya aucun
qu'une recherche
c'est la première fois que vous jouez
les mathari j'ai pas pensé à ça j'ai
fait beaucoup de films policiers donc
oui c'est possible
ces espionnes comment se porte votre
carrière vers haidar très bien pourquoi
donc dans votre carrière comment ça se
passe la vie encore mieux ma carrière je
suis très personnel je veux dire que ce
qui me touche moi qui m'intéresse c'est
le dis je suis tout de même l'actualité
comme je suis mort politique comme je
suis la bourse comme je suis les
accidents je suis très égoïste ce
dernier a que très peu de chose qui me
touche vraiment
portrait de pierre richard samba quoi
tes grands yeux bleus division d'enfants
surtout et c'est ça qui est formidable
c'est 1-1 émerveillé naïf
[Musique]
l'autriche a encore des malades on aime
à leur danse est terminée c'est une
période faste qui commence pour moi
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre vie
espéces parce que je joue en tant
qu'acteur uniquement et que c'est pour
ça que j'ai une période faste ce que je
suis décontracté
parce que je n'ai plus à penser qu'à moi
mais il également pour partenaire
mireille da alors allons la relation la
balance si je puis dire c'est une
verrerie d'art qu'il fait partie des cds
des réseaus des réseaux clandestins et
elle est chargée me faire parler avec
ses arguments et voiliers de suite et
qu'elle a priori j'ai rien pour remplir
une femme aussi belle et elle est touché
par par cette innocence je crois qu elle
vous attend d'ailleurs sur le plateau
tout de suite non oui elle nous faire ch
s'est passé le matin mais moi je suis
pressé d'y retourner
[Musique]